[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi à 6
avril les départements de l'essonne et
des yvelines s'associent pour exposer la
politique en faveur de la coopération
internationale une exposition itinérante
vient de débuter pour mettre en avant
l'engagement des différents acteurs
locaux pour le développement des pays du
sud découverte de cette exposition
dès le début de cette émission philippe
benassaya le maire de bois d'arcy est
notre invité fil rouge nous évoquerons
avec lui les tensions qui sont apparues
chez les républicains du département
tensions autour de la future présidence
du parti et la candidature de pierre
bédier
nous reviendrons aussi sur ses quatre
premières années de mandat à bois d'arcy
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité les
suite des révélations sur des cas de
harcèlement au lycée de saint cyr
l'école ou encore les grandes eaux
musicales qui ont débuté dans les
jardins du château de versailles
une idée de sortie avec le retour du
soleil interactions c'est donc le nom
d'une exposition consacrée à la
solidarité internationale du département
des yvelines 36 panneaux au total pour
présenter les initiatives du département
de l'essonne et des yvelines cette
exposition est installée en ce moment au
domaine de madame elisabeth à versailles
et parcourra ensuite six communes du
département reportage de patrick jacques
de dixmude et nicolas d'andry
interactions entre des yvelinois des
essonniens des populations de pays
africains
c'est le thème de cette exposition
organisée par les deux collectivités
une exposition pour présenter leurs
actions de solidarité internationale
menée en afrique une politique porté par
le département des yvelines depuis plus
de 10 ans à travers son réseau
d'associations
nous avons à ces d'étendre cette envie
d'être solidaire du monde a de plus en
plus de personnes de plus en plus
d'associations de plus en plus de
collectivités locales
je crois que ta véritable enjeu donc
expliquer convaincre et faire que
d'autres s'engagent voilà le but de
cette exposition
cette exposition elle est construite
autour de portraits des portraits dit
blinois des portraits des soignants qui
sont présents dans des associations dans
des collectivités locales dans des
entreprises qui ont décidé un jour de
s'engager dans une action de coopération
internationale parmi ces portraits
hélène giraud présidente de solidarité
and in france and hum le nom d'un
village situé au sénégal soutenu par le
département des yvelines cette
association basée à plaisir mène des
projets d'éducation de santé et d'agro
écologie dans cette commune sénégalaise
d'un village en brousse tri-zone très
défavorisé mais où les gens ont envie de
faire plein de choses toujours le
sourire et ce sont vraiment des liens
d'amitié qui m'ont donné envie de
continuer à les aider de créer cette
association alphabétisation des femmes
développement de périmètres maraîchers
des programmes en cours de réalisation
ces initiatives sont exposées jusqu'au
29 avril au domaine de madame elisabeth
prochaine étape place de la tour à
houdan à partir du 1er mai si tu prends
ma place prends mon handicap c'est ce
qu'on peut désormais relire sous un
panneau d'une place handicapée à
elancourt un panneau et un message
inauguré ce mercredi en présence du
maire de la commune jean michel fourgous
à l'origine de l'initiative le lion de
ce club local engagé auprès des
personnes en situation de handicap est
dix autres panneaux se verront attribuer
cette inscription au cours du mois
d'avril une démarche civique pour
l'association en dessous des places
handicapées il y aura effectivement ce
petit panneau qui rappelle de manière un
petit peu plus humoristique en tous les
cas une action forte le respect des
places handicapées
c'est pas toujours respecter un ensemble
de cas c'est une manière de faire un
petit clin d'oeil est vraiment
d'insister de rendre plus visible c'est
place ici à des places handicapées c'est
pour les aider à mieux vivre au sein de
la cité donc aujourd'hui provoquer un
peu les gens leur dire est ce que tu es
sûr de ce que tu fais je crois que c'est
une belle démarche et des propos
recueillis donc par patrick jacques de
dixmude ce n'était qu'un début le
mouvement de grève des cheminots reprend
ce dimanche et lundi retour donc des
difficultés pour les voyageurs pensez à
vous organiser et à consulter les sites
internet de la sncf ou du transilien les
conditions de circulation pour dimanche
seront dévoilés à partir de samedi à 17h
pour rappel cette semaine sur vos lignes
en partance ou au départ de saint
quentin en yvelines
le trafic était fortement perturbé avec
par exemple aucun train sur la ligne e
du transilien et seulement un train sur
quatre pour la ligne n la tendance
devrait être la même pour dimanche et
lundi
philippe benassaya bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le maire les républicains de bois
d'arcy
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de cette
de cette grève des cheminots de cette
réforme de la sncf on a l'impression
qu'il ya un statu quo qui est en train
de s'installer
les cheminots dans leur position le
gouvernement qu'on va avoir une grève
assez compliqué quelle est votre
position avoue là dessus alors c'est un
peu difficile de résumer la grève des
cheminots quelques secondes mais il faut
à mon avis que le gouvernement tienne
bon là pour le coup
d'abord parce que il faut songer à mon
avis le statut des cheminots faut faire
évoluer cette société importante et
rattraper les retards qu'on a eu surtout
sur des lignes et sur les équipements
d'une réforme que la droite aurait pu
par exemple sont posées c'est possible
c'est possible c'est possible je pense
qu'il y à une convergence d'esprit entre
le gouvernement actuel en tout cas entre
le maquereau nisme et la droite au
niveau de la de l'entreprise et du
libéralisme je pense que c'est là dessus
pourquoi pas je suis pas au gouvernement
ni dans les grandes sphères des
républicains mais je pense que ça peut
être quelque chose de das et convergents
maintenant j'ai envie de dire à au
gouvernement et aux maquereaux nice
bienvenue dans le réel
la communication je pense qu'ils aient
terminé le marketing aussi grève grève à
la sncf grève des étudiants en grève
oui les mouvements se multiplient et là
on attend des réponses justement du
gouvernement pour voir si au delà de la
communication il ya également de la
compétence alors les mouvements se
multiplient on est à on est 50 ans après
mai 68 alors forcément la comparaison
est vite et vite fait mais est ce que
vous pensez qu'on pourrait avoir un
printemps social très très chargé et
peut-être avoir un mai 68 mais en mai
mais dix-huit je pense pas c'est pas la
même situation d'abord les gauchistes en
68 ne faisait pas ne faisait pas n'était
pas enfin le parti communiste et tout et
tout c'est parti à l'époque n'était pas
partie prenante dans mes 68 parce que
mes sources entités considérées pour ces
gens là comme une petite révolution
bourgeoise voilà parisienne et
bourgeoise donc on en est pas je pense à
ceux à ce niveau là il faut savoir que
on est dans une culture un petit peu
malsaine en france de la culture de la
grève constante il ya des millions
d'heures de grève à la sncf depuis des
années s'est énormément comment peut-on
modernisées et rénovées une entreprise
dans la mondialisation
quand il ya une minorité parce qu'il
faut le dire une minorité de salariés
syndiqués qui bloque une entreprise
aussi prestigieuse que la sncf je pense
qu'il faut sortir mon avis de cette
culture
soixante huitarde de cette culture de la
contestation permanente pour se mettre à
table avec des syndicats rénové modernes
qui sont prêts à jouer le jeu doc et à
l'allemande à l'allemande oui voilà au
plutôt que de bloquer un pays en tout
cas attention pour le moment entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats de
cheminots tension aussi récemment chez
les républicains yvelinois depuis
l'apparition notamment d'une tribune
dans la presse locale qui dénonce la
candidature de pierre bédier à la tête
de la fédération
vous faites partie de ceux qui
soutiennent la candidature justement du
président
du département pourquoi alors transition
un peu difficile quand un petit fils les
tensions sont pas les existantes
oui absolument des tensions sont pas les
mêmes c'est le début d'une d'une
campagne qui doit aboutir à une
rénovation et une récupération de la
fédération dans la récupération je veux
dire par là récupération sur le
programme récupération sur le
militantisme
il faut qu'on aurait 9 ans rappelle
d'ailleurs que david douillet est
toujours officiellement le président de
la fédération même si depuis les
élections législatives un peu disparu du
paysage tout à fait donc voilà bon il ya
des tensions parce que les choses se
mettent en place comme sur un échiquier
c'est toujours un petit peu moi
j'appelle vraiment beaucoup de calme a
beaucoup de beaucoup de sérénité et
surtout à un peu de retenue en une pas
en train de changer le monde
on est en train de 2,2 d'essayer de
rénover de changer une fédération même
importante mais une fédération donc
soyons tout est relatif armés parmi les
arguments de même des signataires de
cette tribune contre contre contre
pierre bédier ou en tout cas sa
candidature il ya pascal thévenot le
maire de vélizy il ya othman nassr ou un
personnage politique qui montrent un
chai sheller il est il est président du
groupe plr à la région proche de valérie
pécresse
elon leurs arguments c'est de dire que
finalement il n'y a pas eu de
discussions entre les élus locaux que
pierre mais distincts peut imposer tout
seul est ce que c'est c'est vrai ça est
ce que finalement le présent du
département c'est c'est s'est porté
candidat seul ou alors il ya eu des
discussions entre les différents on va
dire barons locaux général à remettre
l'express général quand il ya une
candidature elle et c'est un mouvement
c'est un mouvement divy duels
doublement passion avant de tourner
quand on veut être candidat nous
l'annoncent donc c'est ce qu'a fait
pierre bédier il a dit là il annoncé
encore il n'a pas annoncé officiellement
il a simplement lancé un appel pour dire
que voilà il fallait il fallait changer
les choses et être et être candidat je
vois pas je ne va pas je exagérée à
cette réaction il va pas il va pas
lancer un référendum pour être candidat
à quoi s'est il faut qu'on ait nous
aussi son poids politique peut-être que
sa candidature est celle des autres
c'est peut-être ça aussi qu'il y aura il
y aura et pas de débat avec karl et dié
nom m'a écouté j'ai pas ce sentiment là
d'abord parce que je connais pierre
bédier que c'est pas du tout le du tout
le sentiment que j'aime j'ai simplement
souvenir de pierre bédier si vous me
donnez 10 way alizés quand j'étais
enfant je suis arrivé maire de bois
d'arcy que j'allais rencontrer et que je
il m'a fait part de ces de sa volonté de
renouveler totalement le département
avec une nouvelle génération j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un qui était prêt à renouveler le
à la fois le parti à la fois le
département j'ai pas trouvé quelqu'un
qui était considéré comme un apparatchik
donc c'était quelqu'un qui était plutôt
là pour faire bouger les choses et faire
de 2015 à l'époque l'élection
départementale ce qui ce que le rpr de
l'époque avait connu en 1983 c'est à
dire une une poussée une poussée un
printemps bleu on va dire
et j'avoue qu'on n'a pas été déçu
puisqu'on a fait le grand chelem au
département juste une question sur le
sujet à prendre entendra à pierre bédier
réagir justement sur ce sujet celle de
pascal thévenot dans l'hebdomadaire
toutes les nouvelles qui est une
réflexion assez intrigante quand même
qui dit nous sommes pour l'instant peu
de maires à avoir signé cette tribune
car bien souvent le soutien financier du
département est conditionnée à
l'allégeance des mères est ce que
aujourd'hui dans le département des
yvelines
on peut dire non à pierre bédier écoutez
moi je suis maire de bois d'arcy conseil
départemental quand vous n'êtes pas
d'accord et hyper bédié vous lui dites
ah bah récemment oui on a eu on a
souvent des discussions on n'est pas
d'accord on a eu une discussion
d'ailleurs récemment je ne dévoilerai
pas la discussion avant les discussions
récemment où j'étais pas d'accord avec
lui tu n'es pas d'accord et on est
arrivé ça c'est un grand avantage on
n'est pas resté survolait négatif on est
arrivé sur une solution et ça c'est
important de faire aussi confiance à
quelqu'un qui connaît la politique et
qui connaît les rouages de la politique
connaît très très bien le département
donc il faut arrêter les fantasmes je
pense que c'est une petite
ces militants au bord de la crise de
nerfs j'ai envie de dire pour commencer
7,7 cette campagne voilà mais la
réaction de pierre bédier qui veut qu
elle mais elle veut on va l'écouter tout
de suite on est dans les grandes
manoeuvres interne au grand parti de
droite que sont les républicains ce que
j'espère c'est que les choses n'iront
pas trop loin parce que ça va on va
vraiment finir par décourager tout aux
électeurs et tous nos militants moi je
suis pour la sérénité et la sérénité
c'est de se rassembler de se mettre tous
d'accord
sincèrement les petites ambitions
personnelles c'est pas la hauteur des
enjeux alors on l'a bien compris pour
vous comme pour le président du
département c'est une crise passagère en
tout cas un petit moment de tension s'il
n'y a pas de vraie tension au pire c'est
une crise ou mieux c'est un débat donc
juste sortir gagnant on va conclure là
dessus mardi d'une réunion publique à
saint quentin en yvelines et la
thématique et quel avenir pour la droite
et les républicains si je vous pose la
question qu'est ce que vous me répondez
en quelques emea justement l'instant
quel avenir de la droite et des
républicains vous voyez ces terres fonds
dont un programme retournons un projet
faisons émerger de nouvelles générations
comme je le suis moi même depuis 2014
donc c'est plutôt un parti qui se
renouvelle au delà des caricatures et
des dés et dévoila et des
simplifications
c'est un parti qui se renouvellent ça
n'appartient qui va vraiment ivre selon
vous hélène a plutôt être constructif et
ce que vous voulez par exemple ce bel
air est un parti de droite avec un
programme de droite un projet de droite
qui s'est rassemblée puisque l air étant
aussi l'émanation d'un parti qui a fait
le rassemblement entre le centre et la
droite
donc c'est plutôt clair depuis des
années c'est plutôt assez sereins
là-dessus il n'y a pas de ya pas de
sujet je pense ça grands partis lr un
grand parti qui rassemble un grand parti
qui rassemble des des divergences il
faut un jour que les médias comprennent
les gens ne comprennent que si à gauche
il ya des débats et des courants il y en
a aussi à droite
et c'est pas grave naturelle et doit la
danse est un parti politique
quelques questions beaucoup plus local
vous êtes maire de bois d'acier depuis
depuis quatre ans vous faites partie de
cette nouvelle vague d'élus quel regard
vous portez sur ces quatre années c'est
votre premier on va dire mandat local
important est ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui dans le bain est ce que vous
avez
couvert des choses ahurissantes quel
bilan c'est un bilan passionnant d'abord
parce qu'on est au service des autres on
lance des projets on crée on crée des
ddd des comités de quartier du dialogue
des débats le même pas déçu aujourd'hui
des leçons dans l'action se rend compte
de la diversité de la taille en quatre
ans j'ai mesuré en quatre ans simplement
l'autre j'imagine mes prédécesseurs ont
souffert 15 ou 20 ans qui doit voir ça
plus plus largement mais depuis quatre
ans la fonction de maire c'est
extrêmement complexifier pour une raison
simple simple c'est que l'état se
dégageant des communes les dotations
bessan nous n'avons presque plus de
solutions que d'augmenter les impôts en
valeur si on les augmente pas mais c'est
vrai que c'est de plus en plus difficile
que de lancer un projet est de trouver
des financements
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir l'appui du
département et de la région
vous serez candidat n'ont besoin est ce
que vous savez déjà bon bah j'espère
continuer j'espère continuer projet et
j'espère continuer cette grande
modernisation que nous sommes en train
d'effectuer à bois d'arcy au niveau
numérique comme mieux ailleurs
donc j'espère continuer les six ans
c'est pas suffisant comme on vient de le
dire c'est pas suffisant pour lancer les
projets philippe benassaya rester avec
nous on pas vers son résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
l'actualité de cette semaine marquée par
le lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
qui est depuis quelques jours empêtré
dans une polémique depuis les
révélations le 23 mars dernier de nos
confrères de libération sur des faits
sexistes et d'humiliation d'un groupe
d'élèves masculin d'une classe
préparatoire à l'encontre d'étudiantes
de l'établissement alain godon le
proviseur du lycée militaire a réagi
pour la première fois mardi au micro de
tv 78 écoutez c'est une polémique qui
est née de l'identification de quelques
élèves dans une classe très particulière
de notre établissement
[Musique]
le phénomène donc existe il n'est pas
niable mais il est extrêmement marginale
et
absolument pas ne s'étant absolument pas
à l'ensemble des formations de
l'établissement ces phénomènes sont
identifiés les personnes sont
identifiées et les
les et les incidents sont traités
actuellement et déboucheront sur des
sanctions
et le lendemain mercredi nadia et la
députée et les oem de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines a
interpellé le gouvernement sur le sujet
lors d'une séance de questions à
l'assemblée nationale parlementaire a
demandé des éclaircissements sur les
suites données à la polémique
au lycée la ministre des armées florence
parly a répondu tolérance zéro les
personnes impliquées dans la sphère
seront exclues écoutez j'ai donc pris
des sanctions
d'abord l'exclusion de saint cyr l'école
des élèves impliqués dans ces faits
ensuite ensuite le remplacement après
les examens et les concours qui commence
dans quelques jours des cadres qui eux
aussi sont concernés
assorti de mesures disciplinaires enfin
enfin l'interdiction dans les classes
préparatoires de ces établissements de
redoublement pour les élèves
perturbateurs
la ville de saint cyr l'école encore
dans l'actualité macro dit avec le
déplacement de jacques mézard ministre
de la cohésion des territoires et julien
de normandie secrétaire d'état un
déplacement quelques heures seulement
après la présentation du projet de loi
élan pour le logement les deux membres
du gouvernement ont visité la zac
charles renard 1500 nouveaux logements y
seront construits d'ici 2022
reportage avec des images de marion ptac
est saint cyr l'école comme exemple
quelques heures seulement après la
présentation de leur projet de loi sur
le logement jacques mézard et julien de
normandie ont visité un projet de
construction emblématique en
ile-de-france objectif pédagogie et
démonstrations dans ce nouveau quartier
de 25 hectares près de 4000 habitants
s'installeront d'ici quatre ans une
opération
qui est tout à fait exemplaire en ce qui
concerne à la fois la mixité sociale
puisque on voit qu'il y à des efforts
considérables pour à la fois faire du
logement social faire de l'accession
sociale à la propriété de l'accession à
la propriété dans un environnement
réussi pour tenter de créer un choc de
l'offre dans les zones tendues comme en
ile de france le gouvernement souhaite
notamment réduire le nombre de recours
abusifs aujourd'hui trente mille
construction seraient bloqués à cause de
ces recours en france
associé à l'école le projet de la zac h
un renard a été lancé il y a dix ans
déjà
c'est un projet qui remonte à 2008 même
s'il avait été pensé avant mais le
départ c'est 2008 et ça sera pas
terminée avant 2021 2022
donc vous voyez 15 en cadence 15 ans
recommence à faire beaucoup
il reste autant à construire et à livrer
qu'il a déjà été livrée avec un 1500
nouveaux logements au total beaucoup
d'activités économiques
la création de 400 emplois en activité
économique les commerces et les
équipements publics
le projet de loi est lent du
gouvernement sera présenté à l'assemblée
nationale à la fin du mois de mai son
adoption devrait suivre quelques
semaines plus tard
bien avant la fin des travaux à saint
cyr l'école en tant que maire forcément
c'est un sujet qui vous concerne vous
êtes aussi président d'ingéniérie la
structure départementale qui aide en
matière d'urbanisme notamment les
petites communes du département
est ce que vous estimez que ce projet de
loi est long pour le logement va dans le
bon sens qui vise notamment à
libéraliser un peu le marché enfin
libérer les énergies pour créer un choc
de l'offre alors très intéressant votre
reportage d'abord parce que c'était à
sacyr c'est mon c'est mon canton donc
c'est en y était on était sur place pour
sept pour cette visite du ministre
la veille nous avons fait à bois d'arcy
une grande réunion sur la loi élan avec
les sénateur des yvelines pour appeler
une chose très simple nous en tant
qu'élu local et pour répondre à votre
question je pense qu'il faut donner un
petit peu plus la parole aux acteurs
locaux sur le logement il faut faire
redescendre un petit peu cette question
de l'état d'en haut du sommet en bas aux
élus qui connaissent le terrain qu'ils
connaissent les besoins qui connaît ce
qu'il faut faire en matière de logement
je pense que le logement doit être un
grand sujet décentralisateur en france
aujourd'hui
et pour ce qui concerne le logement
social plus particulièrement puisque la
loi et non ce n'est pas que le logement
social bien au contraire mais haut le
niveau du logement social je pense qu'il
faut sortir aussi de cette valeur
absolue des 25% qui nous pèse énormément
puisque on n'a pas souvent la place de
faire du logement social juste juste une
petite juste un petit chiffre et puis
voilà nous avons 17 et 9 % de logements
sociaux bercy pour arriver à 25 % de
logements sociaux à nancy il faut faire
juste simplement et rien que 540
logements sociaux dans la vie civile 25
dc dc pour elle pour essayer d'arriver
aux 25% 2 ne sera pas possible
impossible impossible impossible il faut
prendre le flux plus que plus qu'une
valeur absolue merci philippe benassaya
venu sur notre plateau d'avoir répondu à
nos questions vous êtes le maire de bois
d'arcy je le rappelle est conseiller
départemental merci à vous et boziana
merci ce week end justement olivier
faure sera officiellement intronisé
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
lors du congrès à aubervilliers dans les
yvelines
c'est jacques chesnais 67 ans qui a été
élue par les militants locaux le
conseiller municipal d'opposition de
marly le roi remporté le scrutin face au
maire de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines jean
claude husson et aux morts patients
ismaila vannes jacques chesnais qui aura
la lourde tâche de faire exister dans
les yvelines un parti largement en crise
moins de 300 militants yvelinois ont
participé au vote
l'ensemble sera inauguré fin 2019 mort
pas à lancer la construction de son
écoquartier dans la zone d'activités
paris ouest il abritera à terme plus de
500 appartements
la première pierre a été posée ce jeudi
matin en présence de la présidente de la
région valérie pécresse 113 logements
sociaux de ce programme ont d'ailleurs
bénéficié d'une subvention de l'île de
france 2 730 1000 euros un écoquartier
qui devra répondre à un certain nombre
de critères très précis comme l'expliqué
le maire de maurepas interrogé par
patrick jane
de dixmude c'est une gestion raisonnée
des places de stationnement c'est
également une coulée verte centrale qui
à terme va pouvoir permettre aux piétons
et aux cyclistes décédés d'une parcelle
à une autre jusqu'au bout de cette
longue bande rd13 de 2 800 mètres de
long ce sont des matériaux biosourcés ce
sont également les nouvelles
technologies puisque les appartements
sont équipés en domotique seront tous
fibre est également donc voilà c'est un
panel un ensemble de choses des critères
très exigeants
que nous demandent de évidemment cette
charte éco quartier à maurepas également
le projet de centre nautique
intercommunal ne fait pas l'unanimité
les élus d'opposition de gauche
s'inquiètent du coût du projet il prône
plutôt une réhabilitation de la piscine
fermée depuis 2015 pour des raisons de
sécurité les détails avec camille
lambert et nicolas landry depuis 2015
les habitants de maurepas trouvent porte
close au centre nautique
une décision prise par le conseil
municipal et le maire de la ville
grégory gary astier pour des raisons de
sécurité l'équipe a fait le choix de
détruire la piscine pour construire un
nouvel établissement intercommunal avec
elancourt et coignières géré par un
concessionnaire privé mais l'opposition
de gauche n'approuve pas ce projet dans
notre vision des choses la piste d'une
piscine de maurepas est un service
public est un service public doit être
géré par un organisme public
au lieu de dépenser des millions d'euros
à déconstruire et reconstruire
soyons intelligents réhabilitons la
piscine et faisant gagner de l'argent
omar patients de manière intelligente
dont conjoncture budgétaire qui est très
difficile selon la mairie la
construction devrait coûter aux
alentours de 13 millions d'euros
les conseillers de l'opposition estime
le double ils ont donc décidé de déposer
un recours contre cette délibération au
tribunal administratif de versailles
les arguments qui ont été présentés aux
trois conseils municipaux pour
s'orienter vers une concession sont
fallacieux on va dire incomplet même
fallacieux puisqu'il ya un certain
nombre d'arguments côté avancé qui
induisent les conseils municipaux en
erreur
on demande au juge administratif d'alors
qu'on n'ait pas entendu sur place
on demande au juge administratif une
vérification de la légalité et de
conformité à la réglementation à la loi
des délibérations prises résultats
attendus dans les prochains mois le
bâtiment actuel qui doit être détruit en
2019 est encore en sursis
et pour terminer cette émission idées de
sorties pour votre week-end avec le
retour enfin du soleil pourquoi ne pas
profiter des grandes eaux musicales dans
le parc du château de versailles le parc
voulue par le roi soleil ou le concert
d'eau et de fontaines a repris depuis
quelques jours principale nouveauté de
cette année 2018 la mise en eau du
bassin de neptune les détails avec ce
reportage de mélanie poké miquel et demi
d'eau et unique et féerique majestueux
ferme bio l'os maison
elles font toujours briller les yeux ces
grandes eaux du château de versailles
depuis plus de 350 ans les 600 jeux
d'eau débute au printemps un ballet
majestueux préparé par les treize
fontenay
[Musique]
c'est toujours la même émotion d'offrir
à b le travail de l'hiver
tout a été entretenue réparé pour que la
dès 2018 commence avec de belles zoé et
va durer toute la saison aux sondés jean
baptiste lui jean philippe rameau et
marc antoine charpentier 55 fontaines et
bassins s'anime
parmi les nouveautés cette année le
bassin de neptune
le bassin neptune est un bassin qui est
le plus vaste avec son système de
fontaines ancien de tout le château et à
des plus vastes d'europe avec près de
150 mètres entre guillemets de dénivelé
de fond de dérouler de fontaine par
contre comme il consomme énormément
d'eau il ne peut être mise en doute très
rarement
donc on a trouvé un système automatisé
dans le centre du bassin là où il n'y a
pas de fontaine ancienne pour proposer
au public à cet endroit une activité
hydraulique qui ne soit pas celle de la
fontaine ancienne
[Musique]
avec plus de 100 représentations les
grandes eaux et jardins musicaux sont
une invitation à la promenade dans les
pas du roi soleil un instant suspendu
qui attire chaque année près de 12000
visiteurs par jour
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo 7,8
lipdo excusez moi autour de l'actualité
en direct lundi à l'ats sur l'antenne de
tv 78 bon ok n'a tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]